all right I have incredibly good news
and Incredibly bad news about the
children's book I wrote about critical
thinking you know I joked last week
if someone tries to ban this book it
might actually be a great thing we now
are up against the first attempt to ban
the book and it's from a school library
I'll tell you about it in a moment so
here's the good of the book and of
course here's the copy of the book and
it's fantastic you can find it at
davidpackman.com book a lot of really
good things number one
4 200 copies have been ordered so far
that's 3 800 paperbacks and about 400
Kindle copies it seems with this book
about 90 percent of people want the
physical book for the Kids 4 200 copies
to 12 different countries when we did
this I thought it would be a success if
the book ever sold 500 copies we're five
days in and we've sold 4 200 copies
incredible number one Amazon best seller
in multiple categories including
children's school and education books
this is the number one book on Amazon
for children's school and education
books I don't even know what I'm doing
to quote the failed former president
that's all great we're working on
getting the book on Barnes and Noble
it's not up to us Barnes and Noble is
announcing a major delay in approving
any new Authors for self-publishing I I
can't control it I as soon as Barnes
Noble lets us on it will be available
there we're constantly releasing because
we can tweak the manuscript at any time
we're constantly making little tweaks
and finding small things to correct or
improve it's the same book it'll just
get a little more sophisticated over
time but here's the bad we are now
seeing the first attempt to ban it I
heard from a I I can't tell if it's I
guess it is a librarian or a library
employee at a school in North Carolina
okay she's asking to be identified only
as bookie I like that she says the
following hey David I work in the school
library in North Carolina in a part of
the state that's more liberal but we
have lots of conservative parents from
the surrounding rural areas who bring
their kids to school I regularly buy new
books for the library and for the first
week we put them in a new book section
near the front door I got a copy of your
book and regularly see kids looking at
it I saw the I guess this means mother
there's it's a there's a typo here but I
believe it means the mothers of two kids
page through it whisper to each other
and then tell me they want to file a
complaint about the book our school
thankfully hasn't been overrun by the
Maga crazies so there really isn't even
a complaint process for books so I told
them to talk to the principal or
superintendent they were indignant
saying you can just get whatever books
you want as the librarian
I explained that as the librarian that
is part of my job ordering books I
haven't heard anything since but I will
let you know what happens please keep my
name private and don't mention the
school but you can call me bookie in
North Carolina keep up the great work
okay she actually didn't even mention
her real name nor um nor what school
this is going on at so listen
somebody didn't like something and again
you know I got a couple complaints from
people saying David the kid that looks
like Trump in the book it's it
politicizes the book and now this is
this is the picture of the kid that
looks like Trump you shouldn't have done
that folks
you all know who I am you all know my
show this is it's just it's just a
picture of a kid that looks like Trump
it's part of the thing if it angers
conservatives then so be it Trump lies
about crowd sizes all the time that's
the kind of joke that's told in the book
it's really not a big deal let's all
relax so you can get the book at
davidpackman.com book very important
please leave a review we've sold 4 200
copies and there's only 80 reviews if we
could get three four five hundred
reviews it would just blow the book up
because so much of the recommendations
algorithm is based on reviews so forget
about if you've already bought the book
you that's great thank you
please make sure if you bought the book
that you review the book really
important
davidpackman.com book